and he has now is William Douglas
Campbell he is the uranium one FBI
informant now to protect the identity
mr. Campbell we have had to put him in
shadow sir it's an honor to see you and
we welcome you to the program you have
worked is a operative if I can use that
term for multiple agencies how many
years thirty years and you first got
involved we you were within a Putin
Russian operation within the United
States since 2009 correct actually
earlier than that my work when I was
handed over to the FBI started in 2005
and it was under ultimately formal
contract and an associate partner with
the Russian government in its senior
Russian nucular leadership who worked
directly and indirectly by appointment
of Putin yeah so when you say hand it
over you're talking about 30 years
you've served your country would it be
fair to say in dangerous situations at
times I yes sir you could say that life
threatening maybe you could say that so
at some point mr. Campbell your life's
at risk
you see Russians have infiltrated the
United States of America they're living
within America and at some point you
became aware that Russia wanted to get a
foothold in the uranium industry and
that they were going to look at this
this conglomeration known but we now
know is uranium one and that deal was
going to give them that foothold if in
fact it was approved by nine government
agencies yes sir there was no question
about it yeah and the FBI knew that the
bureau knew it the uranium one position
was a part of a long term strategy of
Fortier strategy by the Russians did
these Russian criminals Putin operatives
when Hillary was Secretary of State
Barack Obama is the President and again
you're there when they first get into
office did they express any specific
Clinton strategy how to get her on board
or did they express any old
my strategy this was a criminal
investigation of people that I had
reported and yes the Russians and the
United States conspirators I was working
with stated the Clintons were implicated
but that was not the focus of what I was
doing and I did not believe until
uranium won approval actually happened
that the indications from these Russians
were solid about the Clintons
influencing that decision were they
telling you that they had confidence
that Clinton would sign off on this deal
absolute confidence did they have
confidence that Obama would sign off on
this deal they were quite sure that
Obama and the administration who they
had deemed and and labeled as being very
weak multiple times would respond
favorably you're a patriotic American
you're risking your life I've got to
imagine that hearing that your country
is weak and your president and Secretary
of State our state a week I would be in
I would feel bad for my country if you
will mr. Hannity I reacted to it and I
challenged my FBI handlers as to why the
hell all the work done monitoring the
successful Russian strategy that I'd
been reporting since 2005-2006 had
fallen by the wayside and Sophia's
approval had been allowed to succeed
what did they say to you Wow what was
their possible that accident there's no
reason I can't expect any reasonable
explanation as to why America would hand
over America's precious uranium when we
don't have enough the agents that were
senior agents that have families I might
add that were accountable to at that
time Robert Mueller who was the FBI
director who was overseeing my entire
operation looked at me and conveyed to
me frustration and said ask your
politics it takes my breath away that
this is an epic multi most spectacular
failure do you think did you conclude
what what is their possible motivation
for people not to do their job at this
high level this is key to America's
national security it was political and
they believed the Hillary Clinton would
be elected president
they were gun shy they were political
and they they turned their back on the
country in my opinion thank you for
telling us your story and the hard work
and the danger you put yourself in for
your country sir thank you it's an honor
to meet just welcome thank you sir